Ukrainian President Vladimir solenski
has delivered an inspiring Christmas Eve
address saying we believe that tears
will give way to Joy his message comes
as Ukraine continues to suffer from
deadly Russian attacks on civilians and
critical infrastructure with Millions
left without heat or running water but
that hasn't stopped ukrainians from
finding ways of celebrating the holiday
season despite all the hardship
Christmas on the front lines
these Ukrainian soldiers in bakmut have
faced Relentless Russian attacks for
months the city has seen some of the
toughest fighting of the war since it
began in February
but even here soldiers are taking a
moment to reflect on the occasion
Christmas during war is still Christmas
the holiday should remain a holiday no
matter the circumstances we have now
you can probably hear the income in
shelling and our guys are responding
but the holiday is a holiday and it
should remain so
all across Ukraine Christmas
celebrations have been very different
this year
Russia has bombarded energy
infrastructure for months leaving
Millions without power water or heat
on Christmas Eve a Russian missile
struck a market in the liberated city of
her son
at least 10 people were killed and more
than 50 wounded
but despite the enormity of the
challenge facing all ukrainians
president zielinski's Christmas address
struck a tone of defiance and Hope
more cheerfully than ever before
to be louder than the sounds of the
generator
we will hear voices and greetings of our
loved ones and our souls even if the
connection and the internet go down
and even in complete darkness we will
find each other to hug each other
tightly and if there's no heat we will
hug for a long time to warm each other
Russia says it has no plans for a
ceasefire over the holiday period
but that hasn't stopped Ukraine from
celebrating this Christmas
so let's cross the cube and speak to
Sergey pettico office the former
Ukrainian Deputy Minister of Justice and
is now a law lecturer at the National
University of Welcome To You Sookie what
could be the Strategic reason for Russia
to launch strikes on the southern
Ukrainian City of Houston at this time
um well Russia is a terrorist State and
it proves worthy of this name there is
no big strategy behind that except for
terrorizing the population
they cannot uh win this war in a
conventional sense and they are lacking
uh the missiles long-range missiles that
they are using sparingly to Target the
electric Reed of Ukraine but they have
enough of the conventional artillery
that they're using along the phone line
wherever they can do not only try to win
this war but unfortunately to Target the
civilian population
before when they were stationed in
Harrison they were shooting all over
Mickey life another big city that is
less than 60 kilometers away now that
they've been pushed on the other side of
nipro they are shooting Harrison
repeatedly almost every day so this is
just the terrorist tactics trying to
scare the Ukrainian population into
submission
the Kremlin claimed on Friday that
significant progress had been made
toward the goal of demilitarizing
Ukraine is there solid evidence for this
um just like any other policy of the
Kremlin that they've been announcing
when starting this war this of course
failed I mean uh it's quite contrary
because uh Ukraine has got the you know
the Best Western uh um weapons that we
needed at the beginning of this war and
uh constantly replacing the old Soviet
weapons would be more uh newer NATO
standard weapons so in reality in
response to this Russian aggression the
Ukrainian military has got stronger uh
more uh more better equipped and uh more
up to date with the with the
requirements of today's Wars so Russia
failed in that just like in any other
policy that they've been declaring
president zielinski marked 10 months
since the start of the war with a fiery
and defiant speech how do you judge the
collective determination of the
Ukrainian people do they do they share
the president's will to keep defying
Russia
absolutely I mean people are just more
and more getting angry with Russia and
uh you know as a result of those uh
indiscriminate attacks on the power grid
people stay uh during this Christmas
without lights in many places without
hitting sometimes without water and this
did not stop us from wanting to win this
war this only made us more determined
and uh more supportive of our Armed
Forces
thank you so much
thank you